a couple of years ago in the main square
of a small Turkish town this statue was
taken down it's the statue of Mustafa
Kemal atatürk found of the Turkish
Republic who transformed the country
into a Western looking secular state
Islamic traditions are shattered a man's
image mustafa kemal is displayed in
public he alts orders all Turks to adopt
western-style family names and is
himself christened Ataturk
meaning father of the Turkish but here
it was and the father of the Turks being
wheeled away to a lesser spot across
town and all this in the birthplace of
one man in particular
the order to move the statue is a
powerful symbol of the future good kid
hey take care cuz I'm Rafael this is the
story of Howard one is consolidated
power allowing him to recast Turkey in
his own image the most pivotal elections
in modern Turkish history taking place
in June
odo an currently holds the title of
president and if he wins the vote the
once ceremonial position will become the
Nexus of political power heard of it he
has one major promise that's an
expression that really begs for
explanation on all and reports for
Bloomberg in the Turkish capital Ankara
we've been hearing it for so many years
now but we don't really know what new
Turkey is going to be like heard one
could eventually hold power until 2028
signaling what some call stability and
others dictatorship it is kind of
amazing that there's very little that we
know about him as a man despite the fact
that he spent nearly three decades in
Turkish politics he's what we do know
her wounds rise to power began in the
1990s when he was elected as the mayor
of Istanbul he quickly became known for
his powerful speeches
[Applause]
but in 1999 through the center prison
after reading a religious poem that
broke turkeys rules on secularism ed or
thought about that time in jail as a
period where he really put his thoughts
together and that really contributed to
the political persona he has turned into
later uh dawuan won a landslide victory
in 2002 with his Justice and Development
Party or AKP as prime minister he
assured him would appear to be a golden
age building schools and roads
introducing free health care and
beginning peace talks with the Kurdish
minority based in the southeast of the
country edwin also led an economic
recovery which saw inflation drop and
the average annual growth rate reached
5.8 percent and he promised
there will be no corruption there will
be no poverty he was quite impressive as
weak and me as a finance report is a
team based in Istanbul and he pushed an
Islamist agenda
gradually and slowly nothing changes
like promotion of religious education
tighter laws on alcohol and strictures
on daily life created a divide between
turkeys religious classes and those who
thought they undermined the country's
secular foundations things came to a
head in 2013 when a group of
environmentalists held a protest in the
heart of Istanbul seeing the protests is
an extension of the Arab Spring movement
early one crack down hard
it quickly turned out in broader show of
anger and the critics called a dorm to
resign but one of the biggest tests to
Irwin's leadership was yet to come in
July 2016 a faction of the Turkish
military launched a coup bombing
Parliament and killing more than 250
people we thought f-16 running just
about our heads dropping bombs to places
that are literally hundreds of metres
away from our houses drums shaking
beneath our feet it was unexpected
it was shocking a huge majority of the
population felt really betrayed that
night I'd want to pay five FaceTime
urging people to take to the streets
the call was answered in a country which
had seen four successful military
interventions since 1960 this one failed
an advanced popularity ratings soared it
was a dramatic time for the Turkish
population and and and the president
really emerged as the savior of
democracy at least for a part of the
population in the aftermath a state of
emergency was declared allowing the
government to rule while disregarding
routine procedures Shonda Lannister
hyaline a new name knows Ali needed
terror get there any effort make another
inner ndon bull Chikara yarmulkes
tens of thousands of Turks have been
jailed and many have also lost their
jobs people from all walks of life
doctors civil servants people who
painted the walls in the Parliament
access to websites including Twitter
Facebook and YouTube has also been
repeatedly blocked and today Turkey gels
more journalists than anywhere else in
the world
this has attracted a lot of critique
from the Western government and from
civil society in Turkey they've been
saying that everyone is using the state
of emergency
target position figures as the elections
approach a shrinking economy and
currency prices have left other ones new
Turkey in the balance and the country
survived just keeps growing for his
supporters he's a reformist and a
revolutionary leader who has changed the
landscape of Turkey but for his
opponents he's an autocrat a leader who
is trying to undermine this secure
establishment of the country so as the
statues of one revolutionary are being
taken down his opponents day and
autocrats may be rising
you
you